before before I start the Q&A I'm gonna
make Gary sign my book because even
though we've been friends for a long
time there's no who knows when he whisk
away in his car so quick story and I
don't know if Gary knows this but we we
have the fortune of I had the fortune 18
Gary at a few conferences early days
probably early 2000s I know what year
was the lobby Clark was at oh three oh
two roughly when we met I think eight
hey okay and here's my quick story and
we're gonna get to Q&A was it was
cocktail hour were in Hawaii nice place
lots of people walking around it's you
know it's 6 o'clock 7 o'clock it's it's
gorgeous and kind of going to a bar
being here for three days is not enough
we need to leave this place and go to
like our own alien to our own
destination for the [ __ ] month and I
remember hearing that it'd be like kind
of sense
nuts you know this is crazy and who
knows with the other people around him
I've never told you this great we're
thinking but my perk my reason for sure
in that story is I think that says
everything right like here's kind of a
good conviction to convince people to
leave and live someplace for a month
maybe it doesn't matter if those two
weeks or a month or two months but the
point was he's dead serious this is an
ineffective way for us to get to know
each other
he kind of pointed me instead like for
example Chris Connie know we don't
really know each other and that my point
is for all the students all the kids
over there that the fearlessness and
ideas that are crazy those are the best
ones those are the best ones so I think
that that's that was my kind of catalyst
to get to know Gary and kind of watching
when he's doing that so I'm not going to
do this by or it's intro or I think most
you guys know we're gonna get into the
Q&A because that's what we are that's
what we're here to do okay and I'll get
to sit next to closer all right but I'll
okay I will do 1 I will do one kickoff
question to break the ice okay while
we're super tight has anyone ever said
this but damn I feel super awesome
effects this feels really good hitting
the weights okay so number one question
Gary yes we got a lot of high schools in
here and I want to know we want to know
what were you like in high school men
that garyvee at that time before this
garyvee arrived so it's funny this is
interesting timing for only like a week
or two ago I posted my high school
report card on Instagram because I was
starting to realize through a lot of the
feedback that people were consuming my
content didn't realize when I was saying
that I was a DNF student in high school
that I was a DNF student like I would
see a lot of people like reference like
B's and C's which I guess you know -
straight-a student culture seems like
these and EPS you know I'm I had a very
unique high school career number one
when I when I started high school the
summer before in eighth grade was when
my dad dragged me into the liquor store
and I basically stopped hanging out with
friends in eighth grade so like every
summer day of that vacation leading up
to high school and an every weekend in
high school I worked at the store and I
mean just so everybody knows not like
not like checking the box like you want
your kid to work more like because I'm
first-generation immigrant more like the
merchants of the 50s and 60s meaning on
Saturday I left my house at 7:00 a.m.
and we got home at 9:00 p.m. and on
Sunday we left at 10:00 a.m. and got
home at like 6:00 like just worked and
so that's number one number two I am
unbelievably I know there's a lot of
faces a lot of people here have some
context for me I am unbelievably not
comfortable being mean to another person
like just completely does not come
natural to me I hate negativity I hate
cynicism and I definitely hate
suppressing somebody or hurting their
feelings so it was very awkward for high
school where that is a culture and so I
had I was awfully friendly with a lot of
people it wasn't that I was like so
popular with everybody it's just that I
really genuinely wanted to be friends
with everybody
third I was trying to sell so much [ __ ]
to my friends in high school like I
would literally take all of lunch
freshmen and sophomore year and
literally walk table the table trying to
sell people baseball cards which wasn't
necessarily the coolest [ __ ] thing to
do but very much kind of where
I was that as as a person and then
finally I say the last thing that sums
me up in high school was we had a senior
breakfast I don't know I've never really
heard of this but our high school
thought it was a tradition like
somewhere in in March or April with
maybe a month or two left in high school
the whole senior class got together in
the cafeteria and they did a nice
breakfast and then they gave out mics
for people to say things and you know
not a lot of people wanted to say things
or snappy things and I'll never forget
my one friend took the mic and he goes
the only that like the number one thing
I'll remember about high school is
always being super hopeful that Gary
Vaynerchuk was in my class because I
knew that mean that meant that he was
going to distract the teacher for
between 7 and 15 minutes a day and we
would end up not working as hard in that
class that was me so any of those people
in this room that distractor yeah all
right so I have more questions I will
fill in gaps as needed but this is this
is about everyone here in the room and
particularly the students so one thing
what once were kind of a quick rule
quick questions maybe not too many
follow-ups and we'll keep it flowing so
everyone can kind of get get in as much
as possible while Gary's with us all
right you've got the mic over there and
oh yeah if yeah the microphones right
over there if you want to walk over so
we can hear you loud and clear and maybe
as as that first brave person's walking
over just maybe hello your name and I
know most of the questions are gonna be
directed for me but I really encourage
you to ask Gary hey man hey Gary big fan
thank you what's your name Martin Martin
who I am I'm the associate board these
people are here I always give back yes
and one of the
is that you tell people that you and me
where you are today unless you mean big
bold moves put yourself out there and
you see what happens and so this is the
first time a lot of the students in the
room here are in the program and so
sometimes they don't get what they want
so I wanted to ask you can you tell us
about a time when you put yourself out
there didn't get what you wanted and how
you dealt with it that's a good question
you know it Jesus um well the reason I
said Jesus it's like it's unbelievable
how much I struggle which we're calling
failures even though I have failures
every day right and so trying I'm trying
to be empathetic to the students and
think about something that would bring
them value here's my thing I'm gonna
take your question and I'm gonna get I'm
gonna try to provide value which is the
following I'm curious who gets to own a
loss I'm curious you know when I put
myself out there the biggest things
mistakes I've made in my career hands
down
have been the things I didn't do versus
what I've done I'm an old school
immigrant I seem aggressive and putting
myself out there I'm ridiculously
practical I've never put myself in any
kind of position that has ever made me
super vulnerable to lose it
I've never bet it all right I mean you
know we took a huge mortgage and
building wine library you know that was
kind of betting it all but I was I was
as long as I was healthy I was running
that business you know to me the bigger
question here is when you fail when you
do a start-up and you fail right who
gets to own that loss is the much more
interesting question that I would tell
all the kids here which is when you fail
when you do this and nobody buys your
hats who owns that I think I own it my
elves are my else your two cents on my
losses don't mean [ __ ] to me and I think
the biggest reason people struggle with
doing things is they allow somebody
else's opinion matter more than their
own
about themselves and so when I curse
or when I you know I have made bold
predictions or all the things that I've
done or I mean some of the all those
fancy people at those conferences that I
met in 2000 when I started vaynermedia
they called me and said they were
disappointed in me this is real life
that whole crew of all the founders who
built trillion-dollar companies who
would listen to me and thought I was
thoughtful a decade ago called me when I
started vaynermedia and said that they
were disappointed in me because I could
do so much more than just build an
agency I respected that because these
were the characters that were building
Facebook and Dropbox and uber and I had
empathy but I also have self-awareness I
wasn't gonna build one of those
companies it's not how I'm wired it's
not how I create wealth I knew that I
was gonna eat crow for a decade or to
build a platform Foundation and then I
would buy companies and run them through
it and that over a 30-year period I
could create entrepreneurial success and
massive building growing so when you
have the fanciest hottest you know I
literally at the time had three people
who are on the covers of Forbes and Inc
and Fast Company call me and say you
basically in a nice way you suck and for
me I just loved it because I couldn't
wait and by the way I just mentioned
three that went on to crush it I had
eight or nine others who raised 40
million for their fancy products and
they lost and they have jobs now and so
like you don't know who's going to do
what my big thing is for the kids in
this crowd when you do something when
you go back to school and nobody bought
your hats and they make fun of you I
just don't understand what the value of
their opinion is because I know that you
got the experience of understanding why
did they or not buy the hats
love it thank you I see some ice yeah
we'll take some applause that's great
[Applause]
you had a question yeah he's ready my
name is Dan Castillo and I was wondering
how do you stand out in a society
saturated with media I think its depth
I think it's quality like people always
ask me how do I stand out how do I grow
awareness how do I get more followers
all the cliches stuff it's always gonna
come down to having the chops right I'm
just being interviewed before I went up
here and the young man says how do I get
to be where you are quickly and I said
you don't you know I think the thing
that is often forgotten in my narrative
is I did work for 15 years building
businesses before I ever spoke about it
or wrote a book or gave a speech and I
think right now I don't look down on the
youngsters trying to build a brand or
stand out because I'm sure if I had the
internet at this stage when I was 16 I
would have gravitated towards it with my
personality I have empathy the problem
is the only way to stand out in my
opinion is to stand out for the long
term you could do a lot of things to
stand out for the next week you can use
shock movement you can growth hack you
can buy followed all the dumb [ __ ] that
everybody's doing to win for a week or a
month maybe even a year to me the
question is how do you stand out forever
and that's being a tortoise not a hair
that's doing the right thing day in and
day out that's the point patience and
recognizing the only people that you
want to be that stand out are the ones
that are doing something of depth and
that takes a long time to create and so
that I think I think about standing out
from one simple standpoint which is
having skills and executing against them
the thing you at fifteen and the people
in here at 70 still have 30 40 years to
go they need to figure out
self-awareness standing out is a
byproduct of you being self-aware and
understanding what you're good
and what you love in that paradigm and
then deploying patience on the execution
of that Delta that's how you stand out
in Gary when you mentioned earlier with
the with the agency model did you know
at that so it makes perfect sense like
you have a platform you build on top of
it did you know the path at that time
did you or did you at the time you know
hey I'm gonna disrupt the agencies
obviously you've been in the game like
these agents the whole Kosar right for
disruption I knew at that time I knew
you know what happened during those
summer nights and Vegas or other
conferences I went to when I was
spending a lot of time with special kids
that I thought we're gonna change the
world and clearly have I I eat my own
dog food I was deploying self awareness
and after a little while of spending
time with special people I said you know
what what makes them special that
doesn't make me special what makes me
special that doesn't make them special I
realized at some point that my ability
to understand human psychology and human
nature and what they would pay attention
to in the future was something I was
trading on I understood consumer
behavior a hair of a second faster than
a lot of people and I had the humility
to put in the work in new places taste
them and then be able to trade on it so
basically what vaynermedia beak is and
was at the time was I was gonna build a
scalable version of my core one unique
strength which is communicating in this
new world and just the same I the way I
heard is you knew your superpower early
and everyone here has a superpower right
yeah I mean and everybody's superpowers
are different right like spider-man's
way cooler than ant-man you know and so
like like you know there is an ant-man
is oh yeah there's an animator
[Music]
and so to me to me the reason I said
that is I also don't think like I don't
think everybody's destined to like build
a trillion-dollar company and like
change the world and and by the way nor
do I think most people aspire to it
especially when they get the taste of
being the last line of defense you know
you said something earlier we need more
entrepreneurship I would argue at this
moment right this second we need less on
oh [ __ ] but I know that's a curveball we
need more self-awareness everybody
thinks they're a founder there's a whole
lot of executives there's a whole lot of
people that are leaving a lot of
happiness in their lives because they're
graduating form or in and think they're
a founder they're not but instead what
they would have been is a great number
three or a great number seven please do
not understand this please excuse me
don't misunderstand this the makeup of a
number one a person who lives their life
every day knowing they're the last line
of defense and has to have a constant
running energy in the back of the mind
of anxiety of knowing they are the last
line of defense and that you know you
know what's great about school and
working at some or working somewhere you
can blame someone else if it fails when
you start your own company when it fails
it's a hundred percent your fault a
hundred you hired that person
you made that strategy during this
economic time it is 100% your fault and
so I think we need more self-awareness
of who you are and that that is
something that I very much believe in
Thank You Carrie let's get the next
question over there a microphone in the
middle and in case you guys are
wondering right there in the middle okay
we're getting that okay a Eurasian
empathy yes favi empathy yes is very few
a businessman like you like your success
that if natural empathy so often why is
it where does it come from
and why is that's part of your mojo I
think it's gonna be something in five to
seven years you'll hear most business
people talk about I think empathy for me
speaks about a lot of things I think it
comes from my mother to be frank I think
DNA wise and she also nourished it you
know what early on in my life I showed a
lot of compassion to others back to how
I mentioned earlier I don't like when
people are upset or so my mom would
extend she would be very aggressive in
making a big deal when I was kind or
empathetic or compassionate later I got
to spend a lot of time with my dad we
lived 45 minutes away from the liquor
so we would drive up route 78 in Jersey
back and forth my dad doesn't talk
he's just an old-school Eastern European
villain we are really different
which meant I had to learn to I
basically talked to my dad
constantly to see how he would react
even like with an eyebrow or just one
word and I started really learning how
to have that relationship so I think
there's circumstance of my parents
created a very empathetic thing for me
which he then worked well for me as a
salesman and as a manager because my
default in every situation
it's why I'm a good public speaker I
only think about the other party because
if you only think about the other party
the things that you worry about will be
there if you're the more valuable entity
in the relationship it's the leverage
and so I think empathy is actually
fundamentally I would argue that Steve
Jobs design capabilities were far more
empathetic than anything else
he understood the consumers wants and
needs intuitively I think a great leader
is only empathetic and so I I think
that's where it comes from and I'm very
convinced and and probably on slightly a
mission to make it something that is
talked about more and you know I think
some of these softer emotional
intelligence skills like gratitude and
empathy and kindness have been
historically associated with women and I
think that I'm an extremely alpha kind
of character and I think it's a little
bit of a enigma but I have a funny
feeling I'm a preview to something that
it's going to be far more common in the
future you know it's funny I often
publicly answer I don't know which then
leads to 500 people sending me emails
that they know and they would love to
charge my audience five thousand dollars
to teach him right sorry I just thinking
about like that um I'm not sure but I
will say this the thing that I've seen
work the closest thing advice I've given
to people that work for me and my
friends that has worked that I but I'm
not so sold that it's building
self-awareness but it might be a
precursor is creating relation
chips are the people that know you the
best that allows a safe place for them
to tell you the truth like you know and
this is why I think therapy is great
couples therapy all these different
things are really powerful it's how I
mitigate with my you know managers like
you need to create an environment where
people can give you honest feedback so
in my office my people that visit me
business associates other people are
flabbergasted by the way my employees
talk to me and I'm super proud of it
they think they're being disrespectful I
think I've created the right environment
if you're if you're comfortable enough
to tell me I suck like then we're on the
right path right and so I think it's by
if you really want to figure it out
like just tactically I think a hardcore
two three-hour dinner with the 15 people
that you know the best family and
friends where you convince them in a
week I need you to come back and tell me
the truth to every question and if you
you're not gonna hurt my feelings and
I'm not gonna lash out and like if you
can ever pull that off you need an
actual real hander and feedback because
people are ideological and romantic of
who they are or what they are going to
be and and then that creates emotional
responses that's why I love
entrepreneurship so much there's nowhere
to hide it doesn't matter you know who
your grandpappy was you know once you
know once you hit in this is what I love
so much about organizations like this I
genuinely believe that people that start
from a lower place have the advantage
now in an internet world because they
lack entitlement and they've tasted
negativity so that they have the stomach
for adversity I think the abundance in
the system in America and the way modern
parenting is around people with
abundance trying to protect from losses
and failure is not setting them up for
reality and I see it every day so you
know I'm out there talking to
organizations I was Wonder this week but
people that live in shelters I'm like
you don't see it it's tough being a 42
year old white man and telling you this
but here's the truth you have the
advantage if you have the Internet
pocket and you're coming from adversity
you've got a different hunger and a
different framework that is far more far
more powerful to for the world we now
live in you literally just stole views
you you stole the perfect Segway which I
wanted to point out over here when you
think about a lot of the students from
bill yep look how many girls in the
house he hadn't in the house right lot
of minorities yep and I think in this
environment in this day and age as you
kind of look at you know these kids and
those ones over there we see you yep
over there on your phone your insta yep
what do you say to them right all along
those lines and you kind of just did
right you know what I really say to them
is bad news unlike your parents and
grandparents who who came from adversity
you have no excuses because they didn't
have the internet like bad news is what
I tell them
like whatever [ __ ] or excuses you're
gonna come up with aren't going to be
true because the internet doesn't care
where you came from what's your last
name what your gender is and what skin
tone you have it's a it's an
unbelievably open marketplace for
entrepreneurship the end so what do I
tell them I'm like you know excuses out
the door like you can't they're not
gonna be able to court like you
understand why my big thing is if
anybody's ever made it with your
circumstance if there's ever been a
person who's had two alcoholic parents
lived in 13 foster homes and went on to
succeed and have happiness the excuse
has been eliminated that's how I think
about it perfect thank you Gary what
we're gonna do one more and I was going
to say under the age of 20 is gonna get
that they're privileged so we're
actually we're gonna go right because
young what do you about would you vote
yes you first surely in a society full
of opportunities for your
what do you know it's time to take your
shot you know first of all it depends on
what your shot is usually the way I
think about taking a shot is if you're
not negatively affecting anybody around
you that you care for it's time to take
your shot right so like I don't know how
you're defining your shot you know I
often give you know advice that is
unpopular around the current
infrastructure I'm the biggest fan of
all time of Education I'm the least fan
of the way education is packaged and
sold right so you know you know the
answer is now you know the only thing
that stops people from taking their shot
are something very black-and-white and
something extremely gray the great part
is other people's opinions you're
worried about other people's opinions
the only other thing is if you've
defined your shot as like I'm gonna open
up a score and you don't have the money
to open up the store
but to me like you could sell in a
pop-up store for one day or on Shopify
or Amazon for one day before you get to
that so you you eliminate that excuse
and as you can imagine there may be by
the tone of today's conversation I'm
desperately trying to get everybody into
their own head and get like if I could
wish anything for anybody here besides
health it would be to be able to be so
emotionally strong that you're able to
shut out every voice for your own and if
your own voice is telling you you suck
in this an act you need to understand
that somebody said that to you and that
you need to work and chip away at that
and change that voice we have one time
for one more I believe so
see what are your hopes and I you have
like a different phrase every day so my
question is how can you relate to
everybody in the world that's awfully
nice you know honestly I think I think
what's happening for me and what I would
wish for so many more look I have my
thing but but I do believe a lot of
people here could do a lot of more good
if they didn't think about creating and
if they didn't over think about what
they said and they just spoke about
their truth you know people like oh
you're such a good speaker I'm like yeah
I just talk about what I'm living I
don't have to create anything there's no
deck there's I only talk about very
narrow things of what I understand I
think the thing that's resonating and
why you'll say that to me and why the
other day I'm at the airport
and this 92 year old woman came up
dating she's like your instagrams the
[ __ ] oh my god is because I think the
one thing that ties that together from
that huge range is I speak my truth I'm
not on Instagram trying to come up with
quotes to get more likes I'm on
Instagram because I enjoy communicating
and so I think the reason I'm able to
continue to post so much is because I'm
just speaking what's what I'm thinking
about at that moment to me I'm doing so
much in my life
that themes are popping up all the time
I'm affected by this hour right now
right and your questions and what you're
thinking I like inevitably I'm gonna go
in the car and
Micra wait to my next meeting and I may
think about something that was brought
up or like how you zoomed in on Anthony
like that mean that's like I know for a
fact especially how you asked it that's
gonna play for me quite a bit
or how seeing this young man again last
time in Singapore four months later or
five months later we see him again and
guess what he's still [ __ ] impatient
and he's been listening and he's
listening and he's listening to me and
he's impatient and so I'm like why can't
I break through to him and everybody
else on this and so all these themes
will happen right and so I think the I
think I think I'm able to do it because
I'm just living my truth through and
through and I think a lot of people are
trying to gain
or get short-term like feelings like
that people are playing for the wrong
reasons so we're gonna do well first of
all Gary thank you so much honey happen
[Applause]
sponsors
everybody that's been working hard clean
up to then and I also want to give a
huge shout out to the strategy if if the
youngsters are over there and you put
the food there that was [ __ ] smart
that Gary's gonna be here for a little
bit
he's got some books please get his book
and Gary we are here obviously we're for
the kids we're here for you as well huge
round of applause for Gary
[Applause]
[Music]